first step is who's my protagonist who
takes the the decision and action that
uh brings about the climactic action the
the deepest the subconscious the true
motives that are driving
uh a character can never be and should
never be
explained
they should be
implied but of course the the desire to
be free as an artist is one of the most
suicidal notions you can have you do not
wish to be free
what you wish is to impose upon yourself
creative limitations
uh desire is the key what does this
character want consciously
and in a complex character uh what does
this character want
subconsciously
that somehow is contradicting
um his conscious desire or her conscious
desire what you do
is you put your character under pressure
you first of all have to understand who
your character is then you have to put
them under pressure let them make
choices take actions and instantly if
you do it beautifully
instantly the audience of the reader
[Music]
and they get it one of them in the end
you gotta hit you can have flaws
problems but while them in the end
and you've got to hit
your characters
must change
and the change must come from them
the first question to identify
is who's the protagonist of this story
and generally it's going to be the point
of view character the character with
whom uh we spend the most time
uh but there are exceptions and so if
you for if you've got a film for example
you can go to the end of the film
and in your study start there
and discover who makes the crisis
decision to take uh the climactic action
uh that would be the protagonist who is
the character who carries out the crisis
decision climactic action um and so that
character may appear late in the film
that
character may share the uh the film with
another character and so forth so anyway
that
first step is who's my protagonist
uh who's determining who takes the the
decision and action that brings about
the climactic action uh because writers
like all artists i would imagine uh wish
to be free
they don't like the idea of limitation
they want to be free free to do anything
that they want
but of course the the desire to be free
as an artist is one of the most suicidal
notions you can have
you do not wish to be free
what you wish is to impose upon yourself
creative limitations
and the setting is the first level of
creative limitation only certain things
are possible and are probable in certain
worlds and that strict limitation of
what can happen in that particular world
will rather than inhibit you it will
inspire you
i promise
the the deepest the subconscious the
true
motives that are driving
uh a character
uh can never be and should never be
explained
they should be
implied
what you do
is you put your character under pressure
when
things are
really at stake when when when
the forces of life are are compelling
the character to make a choice and take
an action in an effort to put their life
back into balance
how that character chooses that specific
character
what they choose to do under that
specific pressure is who
they are and as a result the audience's
mind the reader's mind goes through the
surface
and goes ah
we
understand who they are by implication
of their action
so that's how you do it
you first of all have to understand who
your character is then you have to put
them under pressure let them make
choices take actions
and instantly if you do it beautifully
instantly the audience of the reader
goes
wow
and they get it
uh desire is the key what does this
character want consciously
and in a complex character
what does this character want
subconsciously
that somehow is contradicting
um his conscious desire or her conscious
desire
uh is there a deep inner conflict in
this character between what they think
they want
in this uh in this situation
uh uh what they want out of life and
what they
are they their own worst enemy is there
an unconscious desire that contradicts
that um
an exercise in imagination
um
that you would sit down
and if you can draw
fine
uh draw a character
as best you can or if
not create word pictures of the the
character
uh
their their hair their face their body
uh their style of clothing and just try
to create uh the physical picture of
this character
and then ask your imagination
what kind of person would
he be if he or she
uh looked like this
and um
and follow that
vivid outer
uh
tr all those outer traits of
characterization
uh around and take them uh take them on
the rides with you in your car and take
um and take this character to um you
know the grocery store and let people
think you're schizophrenic you know you
talk to people but you know lead them
down and ask him what kind of
you know grocery cart would he fill what
would be his food choices um
and see it's a simple exercise of
starting with
uh with no particular story in mind just
an assemblage
of traits uh including the voice and how
this character might talk and you come
to know this character this imaginary
character
they will um they'll begin to suggest to
you
that they have desires
that they might you know when you take
them in the grocery store they might
want
uh something to eat that would be really
surprising and then you might ask them
why and
they might have a reason out of their
life history why
this food uh they begin to have certain
desires
uh and um uh and that's when you begin
to trace uh what the character wants
and if you can stay with that character
long enough
and try
one desire versus another to make a list
of these things you may come up with
something that will surprise you
in terms of what is the characters
really
deep desire
if they handle exposition beautifully
generally means this is somebody who's
really
even though they haven't been made or
produced or whatever this is somebody
who has thought deeply about the craft
and knows how to draw the reader into
their story and not tell them and burden
them with exposition too soon and too
heavy-handedly but draws it with
curiosity and empathy into the story and
in directly invisibly as it were we're
gathering in the exposition that we know
but we're not conscious of it that that
technique alone
requires years of practice
and
trial and error and so the answer is
always yes
you could do anything you want but does
it work or not work
and and you know often you're never
going to get an answer to that until you
finally write it
and put it in front of people see how
they react
to figure out
does does does it work or not
um
and um and so you have to uh
you have to experiment and try
and test it on people and the answer is
um
could i do it of course you could do it
uh
the reason is why are you doing it
and
and how do you make it work my first uh
and best piece of advice is learn to
think in terms of contradictions
create dimensionality in characters by
building consistent contradictions
within the character
and so um
in one scene or in many scenes perhaps
to certain kinds of characters
your protagonist is a very kind person
but they're also capable of turning
around in different situations with
different kinds of characters and
behaving with
with great cruelty and this
contradiction between kindness and
cruelty at one moment they're they're
they're very gentle and loving
but for other people at other times
they're really hard assed
and even
sadistic thinking in terms of dynamic
contradiction like that begins to build
uh dimensional characters ask yourself
what are your favorite films
or if you want to write prose what's
your favorite novels what's your
favorite plays what's the what is the if
you had to go to a desert island you
know what would be the six um stories
that you would take with you as you
watch them ask yourself what is the most
attractive aspect of that story to you
what do you really love about that story
is it one of the characters is it a
relationship between the two characters
is it the events that turn somehow in in
surprising and uh very
pleasing ways for you is that the
setting of the story
see if there's a pattern see if it's
always character if it's always event if
it's always uh some aspect of setting uh
some kind of a particular sense of humor
certain jokes that you respond to
certain emotions that certain scenes
cause you to feel in character-driven
stories is the payoff always emotional
um
i i don't think always i don't i mean i
can't
you know i'm sure that there are there
are payoffs and character-driven stories
there may be a payoff there may be
um
in which we get a an understanding an
intellectual understanding of ah this is
what caused this character to behave the
way they are behaving okay and so you
have an insight into the psychology
that is a pure
kind of clinical insight
um
the classic cliche you know the the
child
uh uh an abused childhood okay
um
but i would think
that that
if we care about this character and
we're involved
that the discovery of a particular
abuse
would have um
a
intellectual power and so i i would the
answer is
could a turning point reveal something
that is only
a clinical kind of
intellectual
knowledge yes
without any emotion surrounding it the
answer would be yes
uh but then the next question would be
why would you want to do that
why would you just want to give
information
from the past why haven't you told the
story in such a way
that when we discover
uh that what happened in the past that
it uh
it does it
it
it
deeply moves us
you